the question is what should we be
cognizant of as new technologies emerge
in fact it's it's a very good question
and answers itself we should be
cognizant of the new technologies the
pattern that we see where regulations to
don't know that we should see is it the
private sector innovates that's a good
thing because they create the wealth the
private sector and those innovations
generally succeed if they have
value-added to the public which decides
whether or not to buy them to
participate in them at some point
innovation will reach a kind of critical
mass and it will so change the situation
that you need new rules and the problems
come in from this standpoint when the
regulations lag the state of the art and
when innovations have created new
phenomenon that are not well regulated
in 1850 they weren't very large
enterprises in America so there were no
national economic policy no antitrust no
general national economic regulation by
1890 we had big well big steel because
there so they had to in the turn of the
20th century come up with national rules
forty years later you now had a large
enterprises that were financed through
stops but there were no rules for the
stock market and for mutual funds etc so
under the New Deal they created the
Securities Exchange regulations mutual
fund regulations that worked well for
about 50 years but by the 80s you had a
lot of money coming into the system
outside of the banks because you had oil
countries with a lot of money you had
Asian countries with large balances of
payment and our financial system was set
up to regulate loans now the pub he was
loans it was stopped earlier loans were
generally made by banks up until the 80s
but after the 80s a lot of loans were
made by non banks and they weren't
regulated there were also you got
information technology it was now
possible beginning in the 80s for an
entity to make a lot of loans and then
instead of waiting for each individual
to repay the loan package of
into a security process is called
securitization and sell it and sell
pieces of it so you bought now as an
investor pieces of a thousand loans you
couldn't keep track you don't know if
any good there were no rules for that
situation people who lend money and
expect the borrower to repay are careful
about the quality of the borrower people
who lend money and then sell the loans
to others don't worry as much so what
happened in the 80s 90s and into the
turn of the 21st century was a lot of
innovations that had no rules what we
did in the financial reform bill was to
create new rules and I believe we now
have a fairly good set of rules for the
current situation the next issue was
okay what what do we look out for and
the answer is we don't know what to look
out for because we don't know what the
innovations will be of the future but
what we did do was to give the
regulator's in this case the power to
adopt new rules as new phenomena come up
in other words we did two things we had
a kind of backward looking set of rules
okay we're going to regulate
securitization derivatives etc but we're
also going to give these regulated
regulatory bodies information and the
authority to adopt new rules as new
things come up so short answer what
should we be looking for we should be
looking for the new phenomena that will
ultimately transform the situation and
not wait towards that bulls that that
never liked them